it's the biggest cinematic event in
years an Avengers infinity war doesn't
disappoint
shocking fans with all sorts of stuff
that weren't totally about to spoil
seriously this video is full of spoilers
what kind of spoilers well like this
spoiler at the end of infinity war half
the universe was wiped out with a single
snap of fantasies giant purple hotdog
fingers but considering the deaths were
supposedly random fans couldn't help but
notice that all of the founding Avengers
somehow survived so why did these
specific characters gain plot immunity
here's a look at the real reasons these
offenders survived infinity war bringing
the series full circle 2012's the
Avengers brought the Marvel Cinematic
Universe together for the first time
weaving together heroes from separate
franchises into one blockbuster behemoth
that changed the face of cinema plus it
also introduced the threat of fan oohs
and a ki mid-credits scene teaser so
it's only fitting that 2019 Avengers 4
will bring the franchise full circle
with the original team reassembling to
save the universe one last time it's no
coincidence that Captain America Iron
Man Thor Hulk and Black Widow
all survived Thanos finger snap and
although Hawkeye was missing from
infinity war it's already been confirmed
that Jeremy Renner will be in Avengers 4
it all began with these six Avengers and
it looks like it's probably going to end
with them as well the last hurrah though
the details of their contracts aren't
made public comments from stars like
Robert Downey jr. and Chris Evans have
hinted at the fact that many of the key
players in the MCU are apparently
nearing the ends of their contracts and
may not be back though Chris Hemsworth
has indicated he might be up for another
Thor film Evans has been pretty clear
that he's ready to move on to something
else a lot of our contracts are through
I mean we will myself Downey Hemsworth
we all kind of started ball roughly at
the same time and I think we all through
Avengers 4 kind of wrap it up with
Captain America and possibly Iron Man
set to depart the series for good it
makes sense for them to be the heart of
ventures 4 just as they've been the
heart of the MCU for the past 10 years
one or both of them may even sacrifice
himself to set the universe right cap
story is about always doing what's right
no matter how hard it gets
well Iron Man's arc is about a self
man learning to be selfless so putting
it all on the line would make perfect
sense for either or both of them iron
man's destiny in infinity war Doctor
Strange uses the time stone to look at
14 million 605 possible futures and
finds only one in which the heroes
managed to defeat Thanos later when
Thanos is about to kill Tony Stark
strange gives him the time stone in
return for Tony's life telling Tony it's
the only way it's clear that Iron Man is
key to whatever secret plan dr. strange
has formulated which makes sense as
Starks character arc for the past
several years has been all about dealing
with the threat of alien invasion and
Thanos in particular somatically Tony
has to be there at the end to take down
Thanos something that dr. strange
apparently knows as well the Hulk's
return remember Bruce Banner never
turned into the Hulk in infinity wars
final battle we were all waiting for
those green muscles to erupt out of the
Hulkbuster armor but the moment never
came hoped refusing to come out of
banners subconscious is almost
unprecedented and the implication is
that he was traumatized by his encounter
with Thanos banners inability to
transform is a setup building to the
dramatic reappearance of the Hulk at the
exact moment when his strength is most
needed which is bound to be an Avengers
for Captain America's final stand one of
the most iconic moments in the original
Infinity Gauntlet comic book is when
Captain America just a regular guy from
Brooklyn stands up to Thanos a death God
with power of reality itself cap knows
he can't win but he stands against
Thanos anyway because it's the right
thing to do he's gonna give up it's one
of the most iconic Captain America
moments of all time and while it's
briefly alluded to an infinity war it
would be a real shame if we didn't get
to see the whole showdown and Avengers
for black widows Redemption much of
Natasha Romanov MCU backstory remains a
mystery but we know she's trying to
atone for the sins of her past as she
put it in Avengers I got red in my
ledger I'd like to wipe it out
what that means is that she owes the
world a debt for the evil things she's
done necessitating the heroic choices
she now makes saving half the living
beings in the entire universe would be
the ultimate way to settle those debts
once and for all war machines
connections of the official Avengers who
survived the finger-snap war machine is
the only non founding member so why is
he still around
well besides being one of the earliest
heroes in the MCU he's also a key
government liaison sure he disobeyed
orders by not arresting caps team when
they came to him for help an infinity
war but with his military and political
experience he can probably smooth it
over and get the Avengers the kind of
help they'll need now that Nick Fury and
the remaining shield hierarchy have been
turned to dust Rockets family one of the
most shocking things about the end of
infinity war is that all of the
guardians of the galaxy die all of them
that is except rocket and it makes sense
Rockets story up to this point has been
about his adopted family teaching him to
be less cynical and selfish with that
family gone it's up to rocket to put
those lessons into play and do the right
thing without prompting from star-lord
or Groot but because he's now a hero
himself in his own right plus he's also
the only space pilot the Avengers have
and if they're going to track down
Thanos that could be a really handy
skill nebulas revenge before infinity
war nebula wanted to kill her adopted
father Thanos and that was before he
tortured her murdered her sister and
wiped out half the universe yet nebula
still lives and we have good reason to
believe she may get the revenge she
seeks because in the comics it's not the
combined might of Earth's Mightiest
Heroes that defeats Thanos and restores
life to those he murdered its nebula yep
in the original story nebula steals the
Infinity Gauntlet from Thanos and uses
its power to return the universe to its
original state
bringing untold trillions of people back
to life around the universe she may not
be an official member of the guardians
of the galaxy or the Avengers but before
all is said and done it may be nebula
who finally gets the last laugh on dear
old dad I will power warship with every
conceivable instrument of death I will
hunt my father like a dog and I will
tear him apart slowly thanks for
watching click the
or icon to subscribe to our YouTube
channel plus check out all this cool
stuff we know you'll love to
[Music]